hey my name is corbin lovins i am a
balasong flipper i won the 2019 ballet
comp championship and today i have been
challenged to do ballasong tricks in 24
levels of increasing complexity
valve song flipping goes all the way
back to the philippines where the
balasong or batangas knife was used in
the traditional filipino combative arts
the openings that they created inspired
the art form of balasong flipping that
you see today there are unlimited tricks
with different styles for each person
but this is my interpretation of the
challenge to me complexity is how smooth
the tricks are the momentum that you
need the finger dexterity and how
technical the trick is before we get
started let's talk safety
there are a couple parts of a ballast
song that you need to know the bite
handle the safe handle the spine of the
blade and the cutting edge i focus a lot
on the safe handle keeps you from
getting cut from the spine of the blade
touching your fingers the bite handle
you cannot touch the blade whatsoever i
am a trained professional i've been
doing this for five years if you are
learning new tricks it is always best to
learn on trainer the edge of the blade
is actually thicker therefore will not
cut you and most of the time the blade
has been milled out now that we got all
that out of the way let's begin level
one double roll out so the double
rollout is also known as the basic
opening this is what you see in all the
movies when you see somebody flip the
balusong open the double roll out starts
in a standard closed position with both
handles in your hand and the blade
hidden holding the safe handle flip out
the balusong so the blade is up and
handle is down rotate it 180 degrees so
that the handle is up and the blade is
down then scoop your hand in order to
bring the handle up and have the blade
out so now you will be holding a
standard open position to close this it
is the same movement holding the safe
handle again flip it out so that the
handle is up and blade is down you will
rotate the balisong 180 degrees to make
it so the blade is up and handle is down
and then you will scoop your hand again
hiding the blade catching the other
handle in your hand in this trick we
used standard position in balusong we
have three positions standard where you
hold the handles of the balusong with
the blade facing out also called the
open position pinch position where you
hold the balisong between your thumb and
the rest of your other fingers and then
we have reverse standard position where
you hold the balusong by the handles
with the blade facing down so the next
level we are increasing complexity by
learning to roll the ballast on level
two rollovers
rollovers are used in nearly every trick
you start to get a feel for timing of
moving the balusang around your finger
the rollover i will be teaching you
today is the thumb rollover start in a
pinch position safe handle out holding
the bite handle rotate your wrist down
in a flick letting the safe handle go
around your thumb you will then catch
the safe handle as it comes around
flicking the balusong back up into a
standard position if you start with the
bite handle out holding the safe handle
and you throw it in a horizontal
position this is known as a zen roll
over if you are holding in a vertical
position with the safe handle out
holding the bite handle this is known as
a y2k so a lot of beginner mistakes go
with timing if you do not catch the
handle at the right time you can lose
control and drop the knife or if you go
too soon you can miss the handle
altogether in this next level we are
increasing complexity by learning to
work with balance and momentum level
three chaplin the chaplain is another
basic of ballasong tricks by starting in
the standard open position you will hold
the safe handle place the spine of the
blade over your pointer finger rotate
your pointer finger
in clockwise motions starting with large
circles moving into smaller circles as
you get the momentum under control going
in a counter-clockwise position this is
known as a reverse chaplin and if you
have your finger pointing down where you
are having to fight gravity that is
called a zero gravity chaplain if you
rotate your pointer finger too fast you
can actually cause the balasong to get
caught up with so much momentum that it
flies off of your finger if you move too
slow you can cause it to just fall off
by not having the balance and momentum
to keep it onto your finger by going
into this next level we are building up
our finger dexterity level four full
twirl
full twirls are only one form of
twirling most twirling is when you move
the balusong in between fingers without
using rollovers mostly using chaplains
so the full twirl starts
in a standard open position we will be
holding the safe handle again as we will
be placing the spine of the blade over
our index finger you will be placing
your middle finger behind the safe
handle you will then roll the balusong
backwards letting go of your pointer
finger and placing the safe handle
between your middle finger and your ring
finger reversing the movements that you
have already done gets you back to your
original position replacing your ring
finger with your index finger as you
roll clockwise back into the standard
position doing a one rotation chaplain
once again stopping with your middle
finger on the back side of the safe
handle this trick is a loop because your
starting point is also your ending point
meaning you can do it over and over
again moving on to the next level we are
going to cover our last basic trick
level 5 fans fanning is another basic of
balisong flipping there are many
variations of fans but i will be
teaching the standard fan you will be
holding the balisong in a standard open
position holding only the safe handle
between your thumb and your index and
middle finger rotate your wrist in a
counterclockwise position torquing your
wrist the other direction in a clockwise
motion you will flick the handle letting
go with your thumb but keeping a slight
grip on the handle in order to have more
rotations for our next trick we will be
increasing complexity because we are
moving out of the basics and into an
intermediate trick level six behind the
eight ball
behind the eight ball is one of the
first intermediate tricks most people
learn you are incorporating rollovers
chaplains and overall a little bit of
finger dexterity it's not that difficult
but it's very flashy you will want to
start by holding the balusong in a
standard closed position with the safe
handle it's extremely easy to get cut if
you start with the bite handle flipping
the balusong out horizontal with the
blade and the handle you will stick your
pointer finger between the spine of the
blade and the safe handle doing a zero
gravity chaplin do one rotation and
touch the tip of your index finger to
the tip of your thumb do one thumb roll
over on the spine of the blade which
sets you up for another thumb roll over
between the two handles you will then
catch the bite handle flipping the
balusong back up into a standard open
position you will also want to make sure
when you do the zero gravity chaplain
you are only doing one roll on your
index finger this will make sure you're
set up for that thumb rollover so
there's often a beginner mistake of
losing control of the balusong while you
are moving from the spine of the blade
on your index finger to the spine of the
blade on your thumb make sure you touch
the tip of your index finger to the tip
of your thumb just like the okay
position for our next level we are
learning a trick that is commonly known
as behind the eight ball's brother
because it's always learned directly
after behind the eight ball level seven
helix
for the helix you will be doing the same
movement that you do with behind the
eight ball but instead of sticking your
index finger between the spine of the
blade and the handle you will be
starting with your index finger between
both of the handles with the blade
passing underneath of your wrist touch
the tip of your index finger to the tip
of your thumb just like we did in behind
the eight ball and then do a thumb roll
over a common beginner mistake on the
helix is as you throw the thumb roll
over your timing is not correct and you
end up dropping the blade completely or
catching a falling blade which is
something you should never do so for our
next trick we are increasing our
complexity by combining
finger work timing and momentum level 8
blender so the blender is often known as
the cousin to behind the eight ball and
the helix because most times it's
learned directly after those starting
from a closed standard position holding
the bite handle do a reverse index
rollover this is exactly like a thumb
roll over just on your index finger you
will then go around your index finger
grabbing the safe handle and throwing a
thumb roll over with the spine of the
blade and the handle around your thumb
you will then throw another thumb roll
over which will end the trick or it can
lead you back into the trick by doing
another reverse index roll over in the
upcoming trick we are increasing
complexity tossing the balusong in the
air and also increasing the danger level
9 aerials
aerials are any time the balusang leaves
your hand and is untouched there are
several types of aerials but the
starting three are the standard aerial
the ice pick aerial and the helix aerial
for the standard aerial you will be
holding the safe handle you will have
the handle up and blade down meaning the
handle will be covering the blade you
will be flicking your wrist up
letting go of the balusong for it to
rotate rotating too fast means you get
too many rotations and you don't catch
correctly rotating too slow you
completely lose control of the blade
either catching the blade or having not
enough rotations to catch with both
handles together in your hand watch the
ballast song in the air you want it to
do one rotation an ice pick ariel is
exactly like a standard aerial but you
are getting a half turn more on that
half turn more you will scoop your hand
grabbing one of the handles as they come
around and the other handle will fall
into your hand you will then be in a
reverse standard position the helix
aerial is thrown on a flat horizontal
plane usually following a thumb roll
over because it's easier to throw from
there and once the blade passes and you
see the next handle coming around you'll
grab the handle and throw a thumb roll
over for the next level we'll be
increasing complexity by doing a combo
that includes an aerial level 10 scissor
the scissor can be thrown from either
handle throwing a standard area off of
the safe handle you will want to stick
your middle finger in between the two
handles while your index finger goes
between the handle and the blade
bringing the balusong back over your
index finger completes the scissor how
you get out of it is your choice the
most common way is to do a full twirl
which we learned in a previous level for
our next level we will be increasing
complexity by using all of our fingers
level 11 ladder the latter can also be
seen when you are doing pen spinning
when someone moves the pen in between
each of their fingers back around that
is basically a ladder for the latter you
will want to hold one handle between
your pinky and middle finger pull your
ring finger towards you and push your
pinky out and bring the handle
completely off of your pinky in between
your middle finger and your ring you
will then take your pointer finger push
on the back of the handle to move it up
around your pointer finger and into your
hand from there you will do a simple
thumb roll over and finish the trick not
having enough strength in your fingers
can cause the belly to fly in different
directions your pinky and your ring
finger are often not your strongest
fingers so you'll want to build up the
string holding the belly too close to
your body while doing the ladder can
also cause harm to your torso as you
move the belly from between your ring
finger and pinky up to your ring finger
and middle you want to be away from your
body so you don't hit your torso you
might notice a lot of the ways that
these tricks go wrong is you get cut
again make sure you're using trainers
when you are first learning and then
move on to a live blade for our next
level we are increasing complexity
because we are throwing an aerial with
an unnatural movement level 12 backhand
aerial it's a little bit more complex
because you are throwing an aerial
unnaturally behind your hand rather than
naturally in a clockwise motion you will
want to hold the balusong in a pinch
position letting go of one of the
handles you will drop the handle and
once it reaches below your hand rotate
your wrist letting go of the other
handle this will cause enough momentum
for the balisong to turn and for you to
catch the other handle bringing down
ready for your next trick this can go
wrong if you do not move with the
ballast song as you throw the balusong's
blade will be coming around before the
handles do this can cause you to catch
the blade and surely be cut the good
thing about the backhand aerial is it's
a handle switch if you have the bite
handle out you will catch with the safe
handle if you have the safe handle out
you will catch with the bite handle what
i like to do is catch the bite handle
coming up into an aerial chaplain for
this next trick although short it
requires perfect timing and great finger
dexterity level 13 shortstop holding the
safe handle in an already open position
as this is usually a finisher do a
reverse thumb roll over where you roll
the balusong backwards over your thumb
catching the bite handle in between your
middle finger and ring finger pushing
your ring finger out and middle finger
in this will then rotate the bow song up
as we did in the ladder and then both
handles will be on your pointer finger
and your thumb you will then squeeze
those together into an ice pick reverse
standard position the shortstop requires
very precise timing for this next level
we are increasing complexity because we
are throwing an aerial where the
balusang comes very close to our face
level 14 van gogh and the neck catch the
van gogh is inspired by vincent van gogh
the artist who lost his ear for the van
gogh you are basically doing an ice pick
ariel but higher and with a slower
rotation this slower rotation will give
you the ability to watch what handle is
coming around and reach your hand behind
your head close to your ear catching
both handles in the ice pick position
the neck catch is one of the only moves
you will be actually throwing the
balusong at your neck for this you will
be throwing once again exactly like an
ice pick aerial catching between the
crease of your neck and your shoulder as
one handle hits you will clamp down with
your shoulder and your neck in order to
stop the ballasong in its rotation an
easier way to do this so you're not
throwing the ballasong directly at your
neck but almost like you're throwing an
ice pick ariel is you can step forward
into the balusong and then clamp down
once you feel it touch your shoulder the
next trick raises complexity because it
requires a lot of finger movement and is
overall the hardest trick we have
learned so far level 15 choker fan the
choker fan was created a few years ago
by a guy who goes by the name sir horse
choker in the instagram community start
just like you're doing a double roll out
you will hold the safe handle once you
get it so the blade is facing away from
you and the other handle is facing
towards you you will torque your wrist
in order to start the fan you will move
the handle from between your middle
finger and index finger to between your
middle and pointer finger and then
finally up into a thumb roll over you
would be hard pressed to find any combo
that does not use the choker fan in it
today so far every trick has been done
with one hand for this next level we are
increasing complexity because we are
adding our other one and moving the
balusong in between them level 16
transfers there are an infinite number
of transfers but today i will be showing
you how to do a slap transfer whichever
hand is your dominant hand is the one
you normally flip with your off hand is
the hand you do not flip with so holding
in your dominant hand the safe handle
turn your off hand in the same way your
main hand is facing and bring one of the
handles of the balusong and you will
turn your hand backwards and slap that
handle away from there you will rotate
the balusong up while moving your hand
over and above your other hand like this
and then flipping that other handle into
your hand grabbing that handle creating
a transfer you will then rotate the
balusong down placing your other hand
above your off hand doing another
transfer our next trick incorporates
advanced movements in a reverse motion
level 17 reverse behind the eight ball
reverse behind the eight ball is the
exact same motions that you do
in the behind the eight ball just
starting at the end first you will be
holding the balusong in a standard
closed position holding the safe handle
rotate the balusong out to a standard
open position and then placing the spine
of the blade over your thumb you will do
a reverse thumb chaplin rotate your
wrist so that your thumb is facing down
do the okay symbol in order to move the
balisong from your thumb onto your
pointer finger from there the balusang
will go around for a zero g chaplin in
which you will stop with your middle
finger the good thing about stopping
this with your middle finger is that you
can go directly into a full twirl in
order to get out of this trick for our
next trick we'll be increasing
complexity by using our wrist in a whole
new way
level 18 wrist bump transfer to do the
wrist bump transfer you will be throwing
a helix aerial but instead of throwing a
helix aerial straight up you will throw
it diagonal so you will throw it so that
it is over top of your off hand from
your offhand you will bump it at the
apex of the helix aerial bringing it
back to your other hand catching and
going into another trick the reason we
bump at the apex is so that we do not
fight gravity with most knives being
titanium bringing down hard metal onto
your hand can often hurt you have to be
very precise with where you bump the
balusong if you do not hit the balusong
on the back of your hand at the pivots
or if you do not hit it at the center of
your wrist you can cause it to go in
different directions often times
crashing to the floor for this next
trick we are increasing complexity by
doing a reverse trick with an aerial
level 19 aerial to reverse chaplin you
are technically throwing the same way
that you do a standard aerial but once
you throw the standard aerial you want
to throw it with a slower rotation this
slower rotation will let you be able to
place your pointer finger between the
spine of the blade and the safe handle
towards the tang of the blade this will
then give you more control over where
you start the chaplain and how you start
the chaplain a cool ending to this trick
could also be ending with a shortstop
for this next trick we are increasing
complexity because we are throwing the
balusong over and behind our back
blindly level 20 modified guillotine the
guillotine was invented by edward
anthonis also known as lucifer on
instagram this trick is a finisher but
today i have modified it as a part of a
combo that you can keep going from you
hold the balusong with one handle just
like you're gonna throw a standard
aerial bend down to roughly waist height
and throw the balusong over your back
seeing its rotation find a handle you
can grab and throw a thumb roll over
this will get you into your next trick
safely and without getting cut this is
done best by keeping it into one
rotation or even a half rotation to be a
handle switch practice many times by
just bending down and throwing it over
you not too long so it gets out of your
reach not too short so it hits your back
but just so it's over your shoulders
able to be caught for this next level we
are increasing complexity because we are
throwing two tricks with little to no
control level 21 ladder aerial to
reverse chaplin so as this trick
suggests you will be throwing a ladder
an aerial and a reverse chaplain
starting the ladder between your ring
finger and your pinky you will move it
up just like we did in the ladder use
the pointer finger to throw the aerial
and get a half rotation to where you can
place
your index finger in between the spine
of the blade and the safe handle
starting with a large circle just like
we did in the chaplain and the aerial
reverse chaplin you will then get to
smaller circles depending on when you
find the momentum in the balance this
aerial is pretty difficult because you
are throwing with two fingers or just
starting the rotation with your pointer
finger similar to the latter this trick
can go wrong by losing control of the
ballast song between your fingers or
placing your finger in the wrong spot on
the aerial for our next level we are
increasing complexity by using a lot of
the aerials that we have learned so far
level 22 extended combos it's not just
these singular tricks you can put these
tricks together any way you want to into
combos this combo that i'm doing i have
done in the 2021 blade show competition
for the quarterfinals i was trying to do
as many aerials as possible in the time
frame given in order to beat my opponent
the hard thing about throwing a lot of
aerials is you can lose control very
easily a little bit more of a rotation
makes you put in a different move and
lose your flow of what you're doing
combos can go on forever but since we've
run out of tricks to add to raise our
complexity let's just take away our
sight level 23 blindfolded flipping
blindfolded flipping is all about muscle
memory you completely lose your sight so
you are strictly going with what your
fingers feel so make sure you're careful
with this one practice practice practice
so you know where the bala song lands
you are solely relying on your hands for
all of our levels up to this point we
have had one blade in one hand for our
last level we are adding a second
balisong level 24 doubles there are
three styles of doubles mirrored where
both hands are doing the same tricks
staggered where both hands are doing the
same tricks where your off hand is
slowly behind your main hand and
freestyle where each hand is doing their
own routine my preferred style of
doubles is freestyle that way i can do a
singular thing with my offhand and a
singular thing with my main hand as my
main hand can do things that my offhand
can't plus overall i just think it looks
really cool freestyle doubles is really
hard because it's almost like you got to
use the left side of your brain for your
left hand and the right side of your
brain for your right hand if you really
don't know how to do freestyle doubles
you can do the same tricks over and over
in your off hand as a loop while you do
something else with your main hand for
me personally i do a thumb roll over
into a half twirl with my off hand and
then i do everything else with my main
hand it's kind of like a smoke and
mirrors type thing balisong flipping is
always changing it's always getting
harder as there's new tricks developed
every day what i hope someone takes away
from this video is seeing that bao song
flipping can be really fun it can be
therapeutic it can be something that
people lean on such as i have in the
past it's something that you can do with
your friends a community that you have
on social media it's led me to some of
my best friends that i've ever met
personally i'm still learning stuff
every day there are people out there who
can throw things that i would never even
dream of and even more tricks are going
to be thrown in three years that we
would have never thought of now thanks
wired